how you feeling this morning I'm feeling
great yeah I saw those pictures of you
with our cup and it's at Chelsea pier
today I'm going to get it back though in
September I hope if you need me to help
you though like motivation I know you
bring in Michael Jordan and Jordan will
probably give a pep talk but if you need
sort of that let me go to the bullpen
and bring in a closer i'd be more than
happy to help you at hazeltine oh well
thank you can you part no no I I cannot
is I've got four pic wet now what's the
time frame for you have to have you have
three more selections right for pics
again they play this week deutsche bank
next week BMW then we pick three then
they play they have a week off then they
play the Tour Championship and we pick
one the last one the night before we go
the Ryder Cup the next week so it's the
last second pic if somebody gets hot can
somebody lobby you pull your side and
say have they done that oh yes they're
they're letting me know how interested
they are and being on the team and how
well they would fit in and it's part of
it and but I want to hear it i want to
hear guys that are passionate about it
they really want to play and feel like
they could add something um and we want
to see it on the golf course you know
that's what tiger and Steve Stricker Tom
Lima and I assistance they we want to
see him do it on the golf course these
next three weeks but really anybody any
American that's still in the top 100 as
a shot you know because anybody could
win the FedEx and then they'd be hot and
putting good and we take them at the
last minute how can you tell somebody is
clutch is there sabermetrics that you
can use their golf analytics you know a
lot of analytics were using analytics
group called scout think and they're
running all kinds of numbers like that
force you know we want to know what do
they do our Ryder Cup record is not very
good so everybody on our team basically
veterans have a losing record but I want
to see what do they do on the last three
holes how do they finish PGA Tour events
what do they shoot on sunday who are the
guys I want to step up and make a putt
under the pressure and then you know you
can see the guys that you know the phil
Mickelson's the Patrick reads you can
tell they loved the stage they're not
afraid of it and that's the kind of guys
we're looking for in our pics there are
willing to to be out there on the last
hole and make that putt force I guess
the only thing that's comparable to this
for these geysers maybe in college when
they were there was individual metal
play but then it's also a team effort as
well is there anything else to get you
prepared for the Ryder Cup no it's it's
tough and that's why I'm we had a great
time at Gillette Stadium last night the
top eight guys the craft family just
opened the doors to the stadium and we
got some messages from Coach Belichick
and Tom Brady on how do you build a team
you know we're individual golfers you
look at like Coach K with USA basketball
right now he's building a culture to
bring a bunch of starter together to be
able to play and that's what we're
working on I think we have fun when we
go to the Ryder Cup and we want to win
for our country or our captain but you
know building a team that's 12 strong is
kind of tough to do we're talking to
davis love the third the u.s. Ryder Cup
captain what now brady and belichick had
messages that they played on the
scoreboard or they were there with you
yeah they uh they were leaving yesterday
for actually for a game down in New York
New Jersey and they took the time to
videotape messages to put on the big
boards in the clubhouse for our players
to tell them you know how much they
appreciated their games but also here
here's what we do here's why we're
successful and I'm it really meant a lot
to our players especially coach
Belichick you know he says you know just
do your job and ignore the noise and
some of the things that have been
important to that team for so long a
great message for our team and it is
tough we're an individual sport you know
it's a mental game for us so we're just
trying to all pull together and and make
a team out of a bunch of individual
golfers any other special guests last
night Oh a andre tippett was there for
Merline back we had foreign former
linebacker we had
jim furyk and steve stricker who did not
make the top eight and Tom Lehman my
assistant captains but those guys are
playing in the deutsche bank this week
jerod mayo we had just Bob Kraft came
and spoke to the whole team showed us
his four Super Bowl trophy it was pretty
incredible night there's a lot of perks
for being a captain and that was it was
a special two days for us hanging out
with the Patriots is Michael Jordan an
official or an unofficial Ryder Cup team
member he's unofficial but he can have
pretty much whatever he wants um he's
been at every Ryder Cup that I've been
to accept 493 I think he's I remember
walking with him watching Justin Leonard
in 1999 the last six or eight holes he's
been a big supporter of ours made us a
great video in 2012 and everybody says
well Michaels records not that good in
America well not even know American
record so he's not a jinx he's been to a
few wins and I'm you know he it's just
great and Tom Brady said it another
night everybody wants to be around the
golfers from every other sport and
that's what's so great about our game is
every other sport they like to play golf
and michael has been a big supporter not
only of the Ryder Cup but of pga tour
golf and we'd love to have him and
darius rucker's come in we had a bunch
of celebrities coming Michael Phelps
came in 2012 instead it was the coolest
thing he'd ever done and we're like wait
a minute you win gold medals is we're
just playing golf and so it really is
it's become a huge events like you know
it's our Super Bowl and everybody wants
to be there what's your favorite Michael
Jordan story I guess my favorite story
is when we first got him playing golf I
had an old wooden driver back in the day
and I'm he wanted to hit a driver off
the tee so he hid mine and it broke and
he thought I set him up that I know
that's my driver I don't need it to
break and uh he hit it so hard that he
broke my wooden driver probably because
he didn't hit it in the middle of club
face but we created a monster with him
he started as a probably a sophomore in
college and he's loved golf ever since
more competitive tiger or Michael
oh boy I'd say close to the same Tigers
competitive at a table tennis or
anything he does hey obviously I've been
around Tiger a lot more than Michael
over the last 10-15 years but uh I'd say
the reason they get along so well devote
very competitive alright a six-foot putt
for the win or an 18-foot jumper for the
win who you takin now this is I want
Tiger 2000 i'll give you tiger the year
2000 i'll give you Michael 1995
18-footer to win the NBA title 6 footer
to win Augusta the Masters I'd take
tiger because in that area he never
missed Michael actually missed it to you
nobody ever shows those for some reason
Davis they never get no they think
Jordan hit every single game winning
shot he hit about the same percentage as
curry and that's not all of them but I
remember about three years or Tiger
never missed so we thought he had done a
deal with the devil or something but
they're both incredible and it's just
amazing that I've been able to be around
to the best athletes in the world and
then I got to have dinner with Tom Brady
the other night so kids you amazing
amazing where golf has taken me hey dave
is great to talk to you and good luck we
appreciate your time thanks Dan preciate
your support Davis Love the third or as
mclovin loves to say Davis Love jr. the
third the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience